okay let's talk just for a few minutes
about the major overhaul that we've done
to all revenue generating systems for
the show
I promise I will not bore you with the
full ad pocalypse story but to give you
the 30-second version
March 31st due to circumstances beyond
our control we lost ninety-nine percent
of our YouTube revenue due to something
called ad pocalypse long and short of it
is that it seemed as though revenue
started to recover but at the end of
June that revenue fell off a cliff and
we now are considering YouTube's
effectively done as a source of revenue
we maybe are earning 15% of the revenue
on YouTube that we once were it's just
done we have to look at other means of
growing the revenue base for the show if
we want to keep growing which we do okay
previously we basically had membership
and patreon and membership came with all
sorts of benefits and patreon was just
sort of here's a few bucks for the sake
of giving you a few bucks and I
apologize I punched the mic but it's
because I'm getting very very wound up
here the story and people requested
people asked for people demanded we
could even say that we have benefits for
patreon contributions as well as more
member benefits and reward tiers and all
sorts of stuff so we're doing it all
we're doing it all this is something I
spent a lot of time on during the
vacation planning actually so first
let's talk about benefits okay if you go
to patreon.com/scishow and you click on
that orange button that says become a
patron we now have a number of bent of
reward tiers that you can see on the
right-hand column and I'll tell you what
a couple of them are that top one we can
keep that up at that top one the $2
level will get you access to new
behind-the-scenes videos that we will be
doing plus you will get the monthly
patron only newsletter it's only two
bucks a month okay at the $5 level you
will get access to everything you get at
the $2 level plus you will get the daily
world famous bonus show which is an
extra show it's it there's an entire
additional show many people don't know
about that you will get access to at the
$5 a month level
the $10 a month level you'll get access
to everything I've mentioned so far at
the 2 and 5 dollar level plus the daily
commercial free full show if you're
tired of watching a 3 to 6 minute
YouTube clip every 90 minutes you can
get the full 1 hour broadcast show -
commercials Suns commercials usually
around 4:30 p.m. Eastern Time every day
the entire thing that's at the ten
dollar level and that will include the
bonus show and the behind-the-scenes
video and all that stuff amazing and
then watching the show as part of your
daily routine you can take an hour and
tune in and it's not like you have to
sporadically watch clips here and there
so I love it I think it's a lot better I
love it and at the twenty five dollar
level on patreon you get all the stuff I
mentioned Plus you will be invited to
support her only monthly live streams
which we will be starting for both
patrons at the $25 level as well as
members this is absolutely huge of
course that's just patreon where we're
trying to get to 2,000 patrons when we
reach 2,000 patrons were very close I've
committed to doing an entire broadcast
show with my hair out of control like
this okay this this may be a bad idea
for if people watch the show with kids I
think it could be a scary thing for them
but I've committed as a goof if we get
to 2,000 patrons and I believe we will
I'll do an entire show in studio with my
hair unfettered I don't think I'm gonna
be able to come in that day no no no
we've hired a replacement producer for
that day because Pat would not be able
to handle it and then we've got at 3,000
patrons we're also gonna be releasing
some new stuff but I won't tell you
about that yet and also membership if
the patreon stuff is the new thing and
you prefer the old school thing you can
go to david pakman.com slash membership
membership gets you all the stuff I
talked about you get the bonus show you
get the newsletter you will get access
to the behind the scenes videos and the
supporter only live streams david
pakman.com slash membership and you can
use the coupon code
I voted 17 to save 40% so we're working
really hard here pat to continue to
improve what we deliver to our paid
supporters because we need them this is
a really really important time help us
get to 2,000 patrons help us continue to
grow the membership base
and we will continue doing more and more
things for you guys